a sweeping new economic law has been
approved by Argentina's Congress
officials declared a public emergency to
prioritize the worsening debt crisis
gripping the nation's economy in
Jerusalem it is necessary to solve the
debt problem in order to pay you need
the ability to pay and in order to be
able to pay the economy has to recover
Argentina's debt crisis has put the
government on high alert the new
economic measures seek to combat
worsening poverty and to curb AK
inflation estimated to reach as high as
55 percent by the end of 2019 the plan
will also implement higher taxes related
to farm products tourism and exports on
Wednesday thousands protested outside
Argentina's Congress calling for a
rejection of the economic plan the
president of the nation said last week
that if we don't like something about
them we can go out in the street well
here we are mr. president and we're
asking for seriousness for those in
favor of the law the measures are a
crucial step toward restoring economic
stability our country was left flat
if concrete steps are not taken to curb
hunger and end poverty things will only
get worse
the government says 70 percent of
revenue recovered from the new taxes
will be directed toward housing
infrastructure and social projects but
some analysts believe the measures go
too far it's more of an imposition than
consensus building strategy so you know
for the for the government it's really
important to show that it has all the
tools to negotiate with the IMF to bring
in more funds through new taxation the
challenge is that the powers are so
broad that it effectively reduces the
quality and effectiveness of democracy
and for any investor looking at the
country from outside they'll be
wondering how long will this last for
will it only be in 2020 or will this
administration seek to extend such
powers beyond that day
the public debate over Argentina's
economic policies takes place as the
nation's central bank is engaged in
talks with private creditors and the
International Monetary Fund over the
nation's debt estimated at 50 billion
dollars manu and Apollo Al Jazeera